good afternoon
my name is esther segura i moved to
miami
when i was nine i'm a veteran and a
single mom
with two teenage daughters who i love
more than anything
and i am so proud to serve this
community as a nurse in the jackson
health system
i chose to become a nurse because my
grandmother was a nurse
in cuba before she came to this country
for a better life like my grandmother
i love what i do i love helping people
it's in my blood i spent eight years
serving my country in the u.s army
reserves as an operating room technician
after my time in the military i attended
nursing school
here in miami and have been serving our
community
for 27 years today
i work at jackson south and i love what
i do
i love my job but when covet 19 hit
it hit miami hard miami became an
epicenter
of this virus and it was difficult for
our patients
but it was also difficult for my fellow
health care
workers and my colleagues
it didn't have to be this bad i'm
supporting joe for president
because he has a plan and he's going to
beat kobit 19.
i know joe is fighting to protect the
affordable care act
and make sure health care is a right for
everyone
i know joe will look out for health care
workers
who are on the front lines of this
pandemic
i am supporting joe because i know he
will be a president for working people
working people made this country
and deserve to have a seat at the table
and that's why i joined my union
sciu 1991
joe will bring us together as a country
and united
we can build back this country better
than it's ever been
i love miami we are a city of immigrants
working people with many different
cultures
we need a president who embraces that
and will fight for us miami
it's my honor to introduce our next
president
a man who will always have our back joe
[Applause]
biden
[Music]
good afternoon everyone it's great to be
back in miami
and uh thank you esther
i told you uh our family has been
unfortunately this considerable consumer
of health care
please all sit down of healthcare
and uh i've learned from personal
experience as my
sons my daughter my wife my family
has learned is there any angels in
heaven they're all nurses
male and female docs let you live
the nurses make you want to live i
really mean it
you're there at the tough times and by
the way
thank you for your service in the
military but also thank you
for the beginning of this pandemic
being a surgical nurse wasn't easy when
there wasn't the ppe
available to all of you as you walked in
those operating rooms
and dealt with all the problems i know
my
son is a physician my grandma's
son-in-law is a physician
surgeon in philadelphia and
the stories at the beginning of this
process when we should have had
everything available
so thank you not only for your skill and
your courage but for your bravery and
doing what you've done
i want to thank you for the care and
dedication that you and all your
fellow seiu members all your nurses
show up and struggle with illness you're
coping with the loss of a loved one
in terrible times so many of you had to
hold a phone
to a patient's ear to say goodbye
to a family member because they couldn't
be there they couldn't see him in the
hospital as they passed
i want to thank victoria victoria
for sharing her family's journey with us
today
victoria and i were talking a little bit
earlier
i was in south asia
speaking with a president
and he asked me what made america unique
and i said
immigration because it's the history of
this
this country and he's looked at me funny
so why is that
and i said because almost everybody
who's come here
other than those who came in chains 400
years ago beginning
came because they were escaping
something
and it took enormous courage i really
mean this think about enormous courage
leave
everything they knew everything that was
familiar
sometimes leaving family members to get
in the boat
and train whatever the means was to be
able to leave
and start a new life to do that you have
to have optimism
courage you have to be resilient you
have to be willing to believe you can
make things
change for the better that's what's
built this country
immigration we are not figuratively it's
a phrase used but not often
fully appreciate a nation of immigrants
that's why we're the most unique
and strongest nation in the world it's
family like yours
and esther's that have made this country
what it is through the hard work and
faith and perseverance the richness and
beauty of miami is built
from the connections of family culture
values that we share with our friends
throughout the caribbean and latin
america
early this afternoon i visited little
haiti
it's been some years since i've been
there when the earthquake occurred and i
came to deliver some assistance to the
haitian community as well as
making sure we had temporary protective
status granted
it's a cultural complex and now here at
the site
named for one of cuba's most celebrated
poets and thinkers
this city is living proof of the
incredible strength we draw from
families and communities from every
culture
choosing america so thank you victoria
for choosing us
and i'm really honored that you're going
to vote for me in your first election
i promise you i will not let you down
promise y'all
let me also say at the top my prayers
continue to be with the president of
first lady
for their health and safety as they're
like so many american families are
dealing with coba 19.
i was glad to see the president speaking
and recording videos over the weekend
now that he's busy tweeting campaign
messages i would ask him to do this
listen to the scientists support
mass support a
mass mandate nationwide require masks in
every federal building and facility
and interstate travel urge every
governor and mayor to do the same we
know it saves lives
his administration just rejected a
masked mandate
for public transportation on friday
seiu came along and said we need to be
protected
and they said no i believe that was
wrong
and not very rational experts say
that universal masking could save
between now
and january a hundred thousand
lives let me say that again between now
and january
mandatory masking could save
thousand lives you know
i backed that mandate months ago he
should back it now
since the president entered the hospital
on friday
more than one hundred since friday
more than 100 000 more people have been
diagnosed with covet
and this week at least 5 000 more
will die cases and deaths are climbing
in many states
i hope the president's recovery is swift
and successful but our nation's coveted
crisis
is far far from over
today my prayers are with the families
of the 210
000 americans who died from the virus
all those families who got up this
morning there was an empty chair
at the breakfast table tonight an empty
chair at the dinner table
where one should be a husband wife
son daughter mother father and nearly
7.5 million americans
have been infected with the virus to
date
this pandemic in the economic collapse
has hit the hispanic communities
particularly hard nationally
the infection rate among hispanics is
almost three times higher
than white non-hispanics
more than 40 000 hispanics have died
from cove in 19
devastating families and close-knit
communities of loved ones
and here in florida where hispanics make
up about one quarter of the population
they make up 37 percent of the cova
deaths
nearly 3 million hispanics are
unemployed
you break that down that that last data
unemployment for hispanic women
hispanic youth actually went up last
month
one in three hispanic small business
owners have taken a hit
and many are likely to have to close
permanently
some economists are calling this what
they call a k-shaped
recovery it means those
at the top they keep going up their
income
but everyone from the middle and lower
income it keeps going down
keeps getting worse it means that
essential workers
so many of whom are hispanic who have
sacrificed to keep us going through this
pandemic
are being left behind by the most
unequal recovery in modern american
history
because while workers are struggling
this is a shocking statistic but it's
true
the top 100 billionaires in america have
done pretty well
just since the covert crisis they have
made an additional
300 billion dollars
the top 100 made an additional 300
billion dollars
for everyone else though they got the
bottom half of that k
downward the downward slide
you're left to figure out how you're
going to pay your bills
put food in the table pay the rent
or if you're lucky enough to own a home
when you have enough money to pay the
mortgage
how to balance doing your job with being
a teacher to your kids
because your school has gone remote
you're asked to risk your neck because
you can't work from home
or the risk of covet are mostly kept
outside because you're one of our first
responders
a union nurse like esther or on an
assembly line or working in a customer
service or
tourism industry or at a checkout
counter
a police officer a firefighter
i know this is an easy time but i also
think this pandemic has just helped us
rip off the blinders in this country
as how inequitable so many things are
people didn't even realize until now
they've seen it
i truly believe we have a tremendous
opportunity to turn this moment of
crisis
into a moment of great progress for the
country
that's why i've laid out a comprehensive
agenda
not just to rebuild our communities but
to build them back make
bold investments in them so we can build
back
better than before the crisis
an independent analysis president talks
about he loves talking about wall street
he never talks about moody's on wall
street that pointed out they did a
detailed assessment of my economic plan
and his
and here's what moody's concluded
they projected my economic plan will
create 18.6 million
jobs seven million more jobs in the
prisons economic plan will in four years
and one trillion dollars more in growth
than the president's plan and
here's how it works i'm not going to
raise taxes on anyone
who makes less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year you won't pay a
penny more i guarantee you
but i'm going to ask the big
corporations and the super wealthy
to begin to fair pay their fair share
it's not punishment it's just about time
you start paying
your fair share
the money we raise from making sure they
pay their fair share
allow me invested in working people in a
growing middle class
when i announced i said i wanted to
rebuild the backbone of this country
working folks the middle class
they weren't built by wall street it was
built by labor
advance racial equity across the economy
to make sure everyone is included in the
deal this time
we're going to invest invested in
creating millions of good
paying jobs union jobs in manufacturing
and technology
making sure our future is made in
america
in infrastructure building roads bridges
highways ports and airports
like i was able to do when i ran the
recovery act for our administration
putting billions of dollars in the port
of miami
creating so good hard
working people with good decent union
jobs
able to accommodate the new super
tankers coming through the
canal generating
some stability my plan will make sure
hispanic communities
benefit from hundreds of billions of
dollars in investments
to fill the cracks in the sidewalks
install broadband
close the digital divide create spaces
to live work and play and safely
and clean energy we upgrade
four million buildings weatherize 2
million homes will create at least
the estimates are at least 1 million
good
paying jobs and save us millions and
millions of barrels of oil
we're going to meet the threat of
climate change and invest in
strengthening climate resilience
where we are already dealing with the
existential threat of climate change
i don't have to tell you in miami i have
to tell you in south florida
or in my state which has the lowest
sea level lowest degree of
height from sea level than any state in
the nation
stronger more frequent hurricanes rising
tides
flooding and no matter what the
president says maybe you should consider
dropping an atomic weapon on a hurricane
coming our way it's not a good idea
it doesn't work
look that's not some distant
future in miami or south florida you're
dealing with it right now
what do you have to do get knocked in
the head to understand it
we're going to make sure the small
businesses come out the other side of
this crisis
with access to capital and the ability
to deal with their debts
my plan will get 50 billion dollars in
capital flowing to small businesses
which should get repaid in employment
and taxes
especially minority owned small
businesses and make another 100 billion
dollars in low-interest loans available
those
businesses to get back on their feet and
stay alive
because you know as well as i do and
nothing communities they are the
heartbeat they're the center of a
community
whether it's a grocery store a beauty
shop a barber shop
the hardware store the essence of a
community
we're going to make investments to
increase incomes as well
it's long past time i've worked with
governor cuomo to get it done to new
york and other
governors across the country no one
should have to work
two jobs to be able to
be 40 hours a week so they're out above
the poverty rate
15 should be a minimum wage in the
united states america period
and for our essential workers i'm not
just going to praise you we're going to
begin to pay you a good wage
ensure you have strong benefits we're
going to ease the burden
of the major costs in your life what are
they
health care we're going to build on the
affordable care act which gave
4 million hispanic people in this
country health insurance
by adding a new health insurance option
a not for public
not-for-profit public option we're going
to give private insurers
a real competitor we're going to
increase subsidies
so your premiums are lower and you can
afford plans with lower deductibles and
lower out-of-pocket
expenses we're going to take on the
pharmaceutical industry
a plan that slashes the cost of
prescription drugs by 60
and think i'm making these numbers up if
we just let medicare negotiate
independently for all the drugs they
purchase i promise you the rates are
going to fall through the floor
affordable and accessible
every three and four-year-old will have
access to a free
quality preschool all the studies at
your great universities and all the ones
around the country have shown that no
matter what zip code a child comes from
no matter what background
if they go to preschool not daycare
preschool
in school at three four and five years
old
they increase exponentially over by over
50 percent
the prospect they'll go through all 12
years
and many beyond and we'll make sure that
low and middle income and by the way the
total cost of that
is called title one program we now spend
15
15 billion dollars for in school
districts that don't have
high tax rates well guess what you
change that to 45 you can put every one
of these kids in school pay the teachers
a
legitimate rate and make sure you have
school psychologists and
social workers in those schools we're
gonna make sure that
for child care for someone under the age
of five
six no one ever has to pay more than
seven percent of their income for their
young
children to get quality child care
because if you truly want to reward work
in this country we have to ease the
financial burden
of the care that families are carrying
even before the pandemic and many of you
know it and many of you are doing it
millions of working families faced
enormous financial and personal strains
trying to raise their kids and care for
their parents or loved ones
living with a disability it's going to
sound strange
when i first got elected when i was
29 years old of the senate right after i
got elected my wife and daughter were
killed my two sons survived after
hospitalized for a long time
i needed help to do my job
i could not possibly afford child care
even though i was making a really good
salary of 42 000
a year more than i had ever made
but i couldn't afford it being a single
mom or dad or a family that has two
people working with young children
it's incredibly costly and by the way
and the professional caregivers out
there home health workers
child care workers who are more often
women
women of color and immigrants and too
often underpaid
unseen and undervalued
that's why my buildback better plan will
elevate the compensation benefits and
dignity with caregivers and workers
and early childhood educators that's
what we're going to do
it's also going to invest in education
beyond high school
we're going to make if you qualify to
get into community college
you'll automatically be able to go and
you'll be able to go for free
if you are qualified to go to a
four-year public school
in your state public college and your
family makes less than 125 000
a year you get to go free
if you're buying your first home you're
gonna have a tax credit up to fifteen
thousand dollars to get there
what happened after the great recession
and this one
an awful lot of you were that
in a range in age from the millennials
who started off
back in after 9 11 all the way to the
people graduating this year
are not in a position to do that because
your jobs have been postponed or
non-existent
but providing an opportunity can get you
into the system
we're also going to protect social
security increase the benefits
for millions of seniors we're going to
do that all in a partnership on lockstep
with the hispanic community
and by the way the president's proposal
to eliminate
the tax you pay when you get your
paycheck
for social security without any means by
which to re
replace it the actuary social security
said social security will be
bankrupt by 2023.
they've had they've never liked it to
begin with
so look the success and prosperity of
hispanic americans is indispensable to
the success and prosperity of the united
states
and of all america it's that simple
hispanic families are responsible today
for 2.6 trillion dollars
of our gross domestic product and
growing if that was a standalone economy
a country all by itself it would be the
eighth
largest economy in the world
think of that now imagine how much more
that would grow if everyone had access
to the tools they need to succeed
by investing in hispanic communities
we're making the smartest possible
investment
with the greatest possible returns that
our nation could make
period
you know we also need to rebuild our
ability to work
with our partners throughout the western
hemisphere
to realize the enormous potential of
this region in the world
to confront those leaders who continue
to oppress the rights of their people
we should be leading the international
effort to confront the massive
humanitarian crisis in venezuela maduro
who i've met is a dictator
plain and simple and he's causing
incredible suffering among the
venezuelan people
to maintain his grip on power the
venezuelan people need our support
to recover their democracy and rebuild
their country
that's why i would immediately grant
temporary protective status to
venezuelans as president so the
republicans
in the senate can't keep blocking it
like they did again just last week
i'll make sure we're supporting
neighboring countries that are being
overrun with immigration
because of maduro like colombia which
are caring for
millions of venezuelans who fled their
country in desperation
i'll use sanctions as one of the tools
for a comprehensive strategy
that includes humanitarian assistance
international pressure
and support for democratic actors in
venezuela to force the regime to embark
on the road to a free and fair election
we also need a new cuba policy the
administration's approach is not working
cuba is no closer to freedom and
democracy than it was four years ago
the fact there's more political
prisoners the secret police are as
brutal as ever
and russia is once again a major
presence in cuba and havana
for my entire career i stood for
democracy and human rights for freedom
of the press assembly and religion
against dictators of the left and the
right
and as president my policy will be
governed by two principles
first americans especially
cuban-americans
are the best ambassadors for freedom in
cuba
second empowering the cuban people to
determine their own future is central
to a national security interest in the
united states
i think it's unconscionable the current
administration is
deporting hundreds of cubans back to a
dictatorship
but there are almost 10 000 cubans
languishing in tent camps along the
mexican border
because the administration's an
immigration agenda
that's the administration actively
separating cuban families by not
processing visas
through restrictions on family visits
and remittances
i think we have to reverse that the
bottom line is that president trump
cannot advance to macro democracy and
human rights for the american people
when he has embraced so many autocrats
around the world
starting with vladimir putin folks
we can do this
we can reach for more as a nation
we can rebuild we can rebuild
the backbone of this country and finally
bring everybody along
america has always done best coming out
of crisis
we're the only nation that's always come
out of every crisis better than we went
in
we can build a new administration that
reflects the full diversity of our
nation
including hispanic communities and
hispanic voters especially in florida
can help put our nation on a new path
forward
and here in florida today as the
deadline to register to vote
ends today if you haven't registered
go out right now because it is an
obligation
every vote will make a difference check
and make sure your family and friends
are registered
and then make sure everyone you know has
a plan to vote
if you can vote by mail vote by mail if
you can vote in person vote in person if
you can vote early vote early
you can vote early in person starting on
october 19th in many places in florida
including right here in miami
just make sure you vote together we can
win
we can't let this pandemic
change everything we've got to get under
control so we can get our economy
working again for everyone
we can come together as a nation i'm
running as a democrat
proud of it but i will be an american
president not a democratic president but
it's capital d
i'll fight as hard for you and your
family whether you vote for me
or whether you vote against me because
there's nothing we can't do when we do
it
together folks
i've been more optimistic about our
chances as a nation
owned the 21st century and i've been my
whole career
there's not a single solitary thing
that's beyond our capacity as a nation i
mean that sincerely
the most talented workers in the world
the most incredible system in the world
we have a people when they stand
together have never
ever ever ever failed
so every time i'd walk out of my
grandpa's
house up in scranton pennsylvania he
dealt joey
keep the faith my grandma when she was
live would yell back no joey
spread it let's go spread the faith
take back this country we're so
much better than this
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you thank you
[Music]
give
baby
[Music]